[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mental health disorders are treatable
but last year nearly 57 percent of those
who needed treatment did not get it we
welcome back psychiatrist dr. Ken
Duckworth and dr. sue Varma along with
our own chief medical correspondent dr.
Jon LaPook good morning Jon Jon you're a
primary care physician and you say
primary care doctors should be the first
line of defense in mental health yeah
and I think part of it is realizing that
assessing for mental health problems
that's in our Lane just as it's
assessing for a high blood pressure or
high cholesterol anything else is in our
lane that means talking to people about
their mood about their possible mental
health problems but also looking for
clues so Ken mentioned earlier any
problems with sleep is the person
complaining of feeling jittery or maybe
just a little bit of tired and then the
things that are more subtle so body
language right and what's really
important in assessing body language is
actually looking at the patient yeah so
can you turn away from that computer
yeah look at the person look them in the
eye and they'll feel safe and people
want to feel seen
[Applause]
therapy is so vital but but dr. Varma
medication is also out there it's also
an option what should people know about
that path medication is such an
important part in can be an extremely to
effective tool as part of a
comprehensive treatment plan we need to
have realistic expectations we need to
know going in that medication takes time
to work if we're talking about an
antidepressant it may take six to eight
weeks it often has side effects dry
mouth constipation headaches most of
those side effects dissipate have a
scheduled follow-up appointment if it is
your primary care doctor that's treating
you to specifically discuss this a lot
of times people get lost to follow-up
they get off their medication because of
the side effects and also recognize that
medication isn't gonna solve all your
problems if this if this issue is due to
a loss of depression due to a family
member getting lost or death that we
need to grieve those losses and not
throw medication at the person right
let's go to Stuart in the audience he
has lived with anxiety for four decades
and more recently depression you have a
question for dr. Duckworth thank you my
question is around my family knew I was
depressed but they didn't know how
severe it had become if somebody isn't
forthcoming to a psychiatrist or to
their family how can you help them
Stuart that's a great question because
shame is a core human emotion and if
you're not feeling it your best
functioning at your best there's a
natural reticence to not share a
vulnerability one strategy is if you
happen to have a family history of
mental health have that discussion
before somebody develops a problem yeah
right that's one idea the other idea is
just to notice the person and say you
know is there anything that you want to
chat with me about I notice that you are
depressed I may not a fly of a full
understanding of what you're going
through but I'm open to listening to you
very quickly when do you know when to go
to a therapist
well when you're functioning or safety
is it is in the is in the name of your
experience and dr. Duckworth I think
it's important to tell people that they
can call their insurance company they
have an obligation to help you find a
therapist it's really important you
can get assistance in paying for all the
best kept secret in American mental
health is your health plan wants to find
you a therapist if you can't find one a
secret no more a secret no more your
primary care doctor is another route
they often are connected yeah there's a
number on the back of your insurance
card thank you very much dr. sue varmint
ken Duckworth and of course Jon LaPook
we'll see you at home later on thank you
very much if you're experiencing a
mental health crisis help is available
that's what we've been talking about
this last hour yeah and we are committed
to continuing our coverage of this
important issue all across CBS news
platforms thank you to our studio
audience and to our guests
[Applause]